[Musik]
hallo
herzlich willkommen zur verlief welt
heute gibt es ein herzhaftes rezept
abgegeben
über die höhe des bonus haben und sorgt
gibt es heute eine lasagne keine
typische sondern anstatt der normalen
notenblätter fallenden blätter nämlich
heute süßkartoffel ich wollte eigentlich
im rat gar nichts sagen weil der markt
keine kartoffel morath es ist keines
kartoffel es sieht nur so aus wie
lasagne blüte eingefärbt aber es ist
einfach mal eine alternative zur
klassischen lasagne jawohl das ist eine
klassische ist normalerweise bricht sie
durch wenn das hackfleisch oben
achtung aber bei der klassischen das ein
fehler meint soost das ist nämlich so
typisch deutsch die gibt es nämlich nie
gegen italien ja weiß ich von meiner
italienische schwägerin und freundin und
hier habe ich eben abgeschlossenen mit
hackfleisch und mit dem vierten käse
hier bei der lasagne nehme ich nämlich
keine parmesan von den alliierten käse
der ist richtig würzig und es passt auch
deswegen ganz gut zu den süßkartoffeln
also den sollte man echte zu nehmen ich
zeige euch mal die wenige zutaten man
muss sondern wir sagen
jedes mal wenn ein deutscher mit michael
so sie in lassan ii verwendet oder
tiramisu mit aussage macht steht
irgendwo in italien in italien ein
kleiner etat jedenfalls herz stehen
bleibt ja also hier vorne sind mit
zutaten für die süßkartoffel lasse an
ihr brauche ich etwa 800 gramm
kartoffeln vier bis sechs esslöffel
olivenöl 500 gramm hackfleisch vom rind
eine zwiebel 2 knoblauchzehen ich habe
ich zwei esslöffel tomatenmark 400 gramm
tomaten aus der dose des vierstöckigen
ich habe ich noch eine gewürzmischung
und zwar einen esslöffel oregano und
halben teelöffel chili oder einem
teelöffel rosmarin eine prise zucker
einen teelöffel salz und etwas pfeffer
und hier habe ich noch 225 gramm vierten
käse und da nehme ich jetzt bin 65
prozentigen daten wirklich tollen
geschmack
zuerst kann ich jetzt die polonaise
vorbereiten das heißt ich gebe ein
bisschen öl in einem topf und lass es
erhitzen und kann dann das hackfleisch
darin anbraten
und die zeit nutze ich jetzt und kann in
der zwischenzeit nämlich schon mal die
zwiebel und knoblauchzehen fein
schneiden
[Musik]
jetzt ist bleibe schön krümelig jetzt
kann ich die zwiebel und knoblauch
würfel dazugeben und wie lässt sich dann
etwa 3 minuten anbraten
es kommt hier noch das tomatenmark mit
dazu und auch die tomaten stücke der
demokrat ist falsch gekauft da ist es
schon bewegung drin
ihr könnt aber auch ganz normale tomaten
stücke nehmen dann natürlich auch die
gewürze mit schön durchrühren und wenn
ihr merkt ihr braucht nur flüssigkeit
könnt ihr einfach das tomaten schildchen
ein bisschen aus spüren
[Musik]
es geht hier den deckel drauf und
schalte hierzu herunter und das ist etwa
5 bis 10 minuten köcheln und in der
zwischenzeit kann ich jetzt schon mal
die süßkartoffeln und fein hobeln
ihr könnt jetzt entweder vorkochen also
mit schale natürlich und dann fein
schneiden in etwa 5 mm breite stücke
oder scheiben oder dem sohne hobel und
dann können dass sie ganz dünn tobel
wirklich wie lasagne blätter auch ich
mache jetzt mal zwei millimeter und dann
muss man sie nämlich nicht vor kochen
weil sie dann auch sogar werden
[Musik]
oecd hier die scheiben die sind wirklich
super dünn und natürlich auch sehr
flexibel und so sind sie wirklich
perfekt für die lasagne
[Musik]
mit dem restlichen öl kann ich jetzt
meine auflaufform fetten einfach mit dem
pinsel
da kommt jetzt eine schicht lasagne
blätter rein
[Musik]
es kommt hier die soße drüber und dann
auch ein bisschen käse und den habe ich
jetzt schon fein gerieben den könnt ihr
entweder mit einer küchen reibe fein
reiben oder auch mit den händen einfach
zerbröseln
[Musik]
[Applaus]
es ist jetzt schon richtig genial aus
und jetzt geht's ab in den backofen
[Musik]
gerade jetzt für dich an ja sei ehrlich
aber kriegt mich nicht okay aber immer
etwas sagen wir so um die hauptkämpfer
sind ist echt richtig installiertes
sagen schatz ist so lecker aus weil ich
ganz ehrlich wie ich das nicht hätte
nein meint ich meine es nicht wenn
jemand krank ist
ich mag vielleicht also sorry aber ich
mag es über lecker also ich will jetzt
natürlich noch bisschen mehr chili rein
machen aber da die kinder später noch
mit essen das man sich natürlich eine
stunde hier du hast nicht kapiert was
das wort gesagt das ist eine
süßkartoffel ist und sogar nudeln bringt
jetzt nähe des tanzes kartoffel und
blätter teppich fein gehobelten darüber
mit gruppenspielen gegen den restlichen
tag oder schmeckt wirklich gut
ich würde mal was anders manchmal arg
einkehr aber was jetzt kommt ist kann
mir gerade so gut machen will
ich finds gut ehrlich also schmeckt mir
wirklich mit den thesen notwendig genau
aber irgendwer wird sein
ich wusste dass also wenn ich die
entscheidung zwischen lindner saniert
dadurch trotzdem was an ihr nehmen aber
es ist noch möglich ich jetzt mal was
anderes aber was soll's langweilen kann
aber falls ihr ein bisschen abwechslung
in eurer küche haben möchte und was
traut dann probiert auf jeden fall mal
die süßkartoffel lassen hier aus mir
gefällt es sehr gut geschmeckt
mit schwarz gelb der schmeckt wirklich
farbe nudeln schmecken noch besser
und das rezept findet ihr auch sallys -
blog.de und ich wünsche euch ganz viel
spaß gemacht das war der nächsten mal
du kannst nach vermeidung oder meiner
meinung fragen sie mich dann ignorieren
aber ich finde es ist ein großes lob von
dir dass du sagst es schmeckte weil
normalerweise macht ja nicht vergessen
sie's kartoffel aussicht doch komme es
gehört die hersteller auf die schmidt
ist aber nur wenn sie jetzt gehen
[Musik]